how i normal french border carbon
fiber this is a new model
situation we gryce extraordinary action
hospitals doctors and nurses don't
ventilate medical equipment such as
pink testing kids does relations and
save a life and then i de club coin my
blog about old to protect  them even from
contamination
minutes late of this equipment and this
can brook spencer and dutton swipe to day
how you accepted
to eliminate for while searching texas
to the import of medical devices and
equipment from country sarah always the
european union
this is good for hospitals and for
charities for shampoo
this is our contribution to using the
pressure and prices of Merkel a
protective equipment and to make ik ben
mooi voor Dubbel
to give you an example in italy
customs duty of 12 percent to the value
added tax of 20 percent is levitt ons
amfes  muscle protect a garment dye
import from countries light shine a a
decision will make them winter type
proventil eaters the average va  lue added
tax rate is en 20%
this is a temporary measure and it will
apply for at least the next four months
or longueur if necessary
how you stand by our health workers and
hospitals and we will do
only come to help them putter